The human eye is an amazing structure, even if
it really has an imperfect sort of looking design. Normally,
light comes in here through the, the pupil, must pass
through this initial clear region, and then has to make
it to the back of the eye, called the
retina. And way here back in the back of the
retina past layers of cells, if the light can make
it through all of these occluding structures, all of these.
Things blocking it's path and it makes it to the very back to this oddly shape
cells here called cone cells. That are actually
interpreted as the color that we see everyday. Now
the visible lights spectrum is interpreted by humans
to the detection of three main wavelengths of
light that corresponds to three main colors. Red,
green and blue. There's a special type of cell
here in the back of the retina, that's able
to detect these three different colors. And it's called
the cone cell. And there are three different kinds
of cone cells that can recognize each of the
different colors. Now these three different types of cone
cells. Can each detect a certain wavelength of light?
Remember, light is actually energy and it travels in
the form of the wave and the color spectrum
essentially correlates to certain wavelengths that our eyes
can see. The longer wavelengths are in the red
spectrum and the shorter wavelengths are in the
blue spectrum. And the middle wavelengths that we can
see are in the green spectrum. Each of
these different types of cone cells are actually able
to detect a specific wavelength of light. Together,
these give you all the colors, all the combinations
of all the colors that you can see.
You know this whole amazing process is possible
because there are proteins, like OPN1LW, that absorb
light at each of those different wavelengths. In the
case of OPN1W, it focuses on absorbing light
from the red wavelengths. So if this is the
cone-cell membrane, right? We're really zoomed in here,
and in the membrane of the cell there are
this proteins. Specifically PN1W, that absorbs red light,
and essentially tells the cell, and then ultimately
the brain, that hey, this is red light.
Now in the case the premature stop codon that
we talked about in the last exercise. The
changing from cytosine to thymine causes a severely shortened
protein that doesn't actually make it to the
membrane. So now the cone cell can't detect red
wavelength of light and it just bounces away. So what
I want you to do is think about this mutation
and categorize it. Whether you think it's a loss of
function, a gain of function, or no change in function mutation.